[Música]
se acuerdan de su salón de sexto de
primaria se acuerdan de quién era su
maestra a sus amigos del olor como a
papel y al lápiz
se acuerdan quién es el niño o niña más
burro de su clase
les puedo apostar que esa misma persona
era quien le llama al en voz alta y lo
que pasa es que entre 1º y 4º de
primaria más o menos nos enseñan a leer
nos enseñan a juntar letras para formar
palabras y adjuntar palabras para formar
oraciones y adjuntar oraciones para
formar párrafos y bueno la cosa es que
por ahí de quinto la relación se
invierte y dejamos de aprender a leer
para leer para aprender
y entonces ahí se hace obvio algo que
conocemos como la brecha de aprendizaje
los niños que le envíen avanzan los que
no empiezan a quedarse atrás
yo soy hermana y su chilanga y como
muchos de ustedes probablemente y como
millones de personas
crecí en la ciudad de mexico en los 80 y
los 90 desde muy chica me di cuenta que
en esta ciudad convivían muchos mundos
muy diferentes mi mundo personal el
propio aunque sin muchos lujos fue súper
privilegiado crecí en una familia en
donde nunca me faltó nada siempre
siempre fui a la escuela nunca tuve
hambre nunca tuve frío y siempre tuve
libros y la cosa es que a mi desde muy
chica tal vez porque crecía una familia
muy empática y tal vez porque tengo un
interés propio en lo social pero desde
siempre me ha interesado la desigualdad
y me interesa conocerla me la he
cuestionado incluso tratado de
solucionarla en mi vida profesional y
académica siempre me he dedicado a temas
sociales pero con toda esa experiencia y
con todo y que llevo más de 30 años en
estas ciudades
explicar qué es la desigualdad a mi hija
por ejemplo me cuesta mucho trabajo me
cuesta mucho trabajo decirle que es y
por qué está ahí porque existe
porque es fea
es difícil para mí
pero regresemos a su salón de quinto de
primaria cuando estamos en un salón es
obvio quienes no están aprendiendo
quiénes están quedando detrás es muy
fácil distinguirlos ahorita todos nos
acordamos pero qué tal qué pasa cuando
cuando queremos diferenciar a las
personas en una escuela quiénes están
quedando atrás en una escuela y en una
comunidad y en un municipio y en un
estado y en el país quiénes son los que
se están quedando hasta atrás
los que menos tienen qué tiene que ver
esto con los niños de quinto de primaria
bueno pues resulta que hace poco el
mundo se dio cuenta del desarrollo
infantil temprano y del desarrollo
infantil oportuno seguro han escuchado
de él y parecemos habernos dado cuenta
de que los primeros años de vida de una
persona son cruciales lo que comemos
las condiciones en las que vivimos la
estimulación a la que estamos expuestos
todo eso se vuelven indicadores de lo
que va a ser nuestra vida a mediano y
largo plazo
para cuando llegamos a la escuela ya
tuvimos un boom de desarrollo ya pasó en
esos primeros años de vida que se
conocen como primera infancia es cuando
nuestro cerebro más crece cuando más
elástico es cuando nuestras neuronas más
se conectan y entonces ahí está la
posibilidad de hacer una diferencia
porque podríamos usar esa primera
infancia para que lograr que todos los
niños en quinto de primaria puedan
aprender mejor puedan leer de lo que
aprenden pueden aprender de lo que leen
y puedan estar en igualdad de
condiciones
pero cómo le hacemos como le hacemos
para que desde la primera infancia
podamos ayudar a estos niños a estar
listos para aprender
libros lo hacemos con libros los libros
son una herramienta increíble para
estimular el desarrollo cognitivo del
lenguaje emocional y motor de niños y
bebés
y no se los digo yo que mi look favorito
es el de bibliotecaria en potencia no es
por eso en serio no es porque los libros
tienen un potencial increíble de hacer
una diferencia real en la vida de una
persona
el acceso a libros en el hogar puede
marcar una diferencia importante muy
importante en la vida de un niño
johann triste que es un bibliotecario
él dice que la lectoescritura es una
habilidad bandera o sea que promueve
otras habilidades yo no podría estar más
de acuerdo con él la verdad porque los
libros efectivamente promueven
habilidades de decodificación de
estructura de conocimiento del mundo de
imaginación de creatividad de
familiaridad con la palabra escrita el
acceso a libros en el hogar además y no
el acceso a libros en bibliotecas por
ejemplo hace una diferencia súper
importante y tiene un impacto muy
positivo en la vida de los niños hay un
estudio por ejemplo que es un estudio
internacional que se realizó en más de
27 países con un montón de variables en
el que se concluyó que tener libros en
la primera infancia en la casa tiene un
impacto directo en la escolaridad en el
nivel de escolar que va a alcanzar ese
niño niño
y además este impacto no es transversal
no es generalizado para toda la
población este impacto es
considerablemente mayor en aquellas
familias de escasos recursos y en
aquellas familias con padres y madres de
niveles escolares bajos esto significa
que quienes más necesitan los libros son
quienes menos tienen
y entonces cuando vio que hay en cuenta
de todo esto me explotó el cerebro me
explotó el cerebro porque llevaba muchos
años tratando de que mi trabajo tuviera
un impacto real generar un cambio
pudiera ser más grande que yo y cuando
me di cuenta de que un libro tenía la
posibilidad de lograr eso mi cabeza
explotó seguro ya para este momento se
dan cuenta que los libros y yo somos
cercanos me gustan muchísimo los libros
me encantan las historias me gusta mucho
leer compro muchos más libros de los que
necesito de los que puedo leer en mi
tiempo libre
soy fan los libros son hermosos pero no
hay nada más porque los libros sean
hermosos por lo que yo creo que todo el
mundo debería de tener acceso a ellos se
los digo porque desde mi corazón
politólogo y nerd me di cuenta de que la
evidencia estaba ahí y de que los libros
puedan efectivamente hacer una
diferencia
cuando cuando caí en cuenta de que esto
era una posibilidad real de que es
alcanzable que todos los niños tengan
libros en su casa
entonces me decidí me decidí y dejé mi
trabajo y dejé las políticas públicas
invertí el poco dinero que tenía y
convencí a mi socia de invertir el poco
dinero que ya tenía ya mi esposo de
darnos un poquito más y de endeudarnos
un poco y después de muchas metidas de
pata discusiones libros sobre primera
infancia sobre desarrollo sobre
generación de impacto social
creamos arte con queso ate con queso es
una empresa social que nació aquí en
méxico que promueve el acceso a libros
infantiles en todos los hogares
mexicanos para lograr eso hacemos libros
increíbles que en series tan increíbles
y además tenemos un modelo uno a uno en
el que por cada libro que vendemos
regalamos el mismo libro a una familia
desventaja
y no te con queso creemos que todos los
niños deberían de tener las mismas
oportunidades de aprender y para lograr
eso estamos convencidas de que todos los
niños y cada uno de esos niños tiene que
tener libros en su casa desde el primer
momento de su vida
este momento en el que les decía que a
mí me explotó el cerebro y me moría de
emoción ese momento creo que creo que me
llegó cuando pude entender los libros
como una posibilidad alcanzable de
generar un cambio de generar el cambio
que yo había estado buscando desde hacía
mucho tiempo desde que me di cuenta de
las diferentes realidades que vivían en
mi ciudad
cuando me di cuenta de eso fue como en
serio fue como si mi cerebro explotara
porque los libros de la nada se
multiplicaron se convirtieron en objetos
de juego de estimulación se convirtieron
en juguetes en torres en telescopios en
arte se convirtieron en risas en
momentos compartidos pero sobre todo eso
se convirtió en en detonadores de cambio
fue cuando me di cuenta que los libros
son detonadores de cambio cuando me
decidí y cuando me di cuenta que yo
tenía una posibilidad real de cambiar el
rumbo de mi país
por qué
porque los libros tienen está
tienen esta ventaja de que pueden estar
en todos lados los podemos poner en
manos de quien queramos
y cuando cuando todas las cosas se
juntaron entonces me di cuenta que mi
misión de vida y la de arte con queso se
estaban alineando y se habían alineado
para intentar y para dedicarnos a ver si
podíamos reducir la desigualdad a través
de los libros
cuando yo le contaba de esto a una amiga
hace relativamente poco cuando le
contaba toda la historia con queso ella
me decía tú sí todo me hace sentido
tienes razón pero entonces no entiendo
porque como sociedad insistimos en
regalarle a los bebés calcetines porque
no les regalamos algo que tenga el
potencial de cambiar su vida y si por
qué no si todos los niños tuvieran
libros en su casa podríamos cambiar una
generación completa podríamos crear una
generación de niños de niños curiosos de
niños creativos de niños de niños que
puedan aprender podríamos generar
un montón de niños que estén listos para
aprender en quinto de primaria
yo estoy convencida
juntos podemos cambiar el rumbo de
nuestro país un libro a la vez
[Aplausos]